Okay, so we are back at the screen. And
what we're going to be looking at here in
this video, this is our final video on
trading psychology. We're going to be
looking at eliminating emotion and staying
objective. And this involves both
preventative risk management and reactive
risk management. So we're going to be
having a look at both of those in the
context of eliminating emotion and staying
objective.
And staying objective as a trader that
trades to a professional standard, a
professional level. And what this really
involves is treating your trading account
and treating trading overall as a
business. Now, it's been a while since we
looked at the competency hierarchy. And so
far, this is the competency hierarchy that
we've been looking at throughout the
the PTM video series. And what you will
have noticed with that is that institute
traders, so traders, retail traders that
come to ITPM, take our online programs and
then open a trading account and then begin
implementing what we teach with their own
money, with real money.
And generally, those guys, those guys,
those guys, those guys, institute traders,
generally are on average sitting between
conscious competence and unconscious
competence. So overall, they are
competent. And as at the time of
recording, we have about eight years of
data of retail traders that have been
through our programs and opened a trading
account and traded with their own money,
implementing what we teach.
And generally speaking, on average, these
guys are sitting somewhere between
conscious competence and unconscious
competence. So something that is
absolutely for certain is that they are
not like retail traders outside ITPM that
are going round in circles at the level of
unconscious incompetence, where they've
got no clue what they're doing, but they
think they do.
And they're engaging. And they're
engaging. Retail traders there are
engaging in a world of delusion, denial
and lies. Now, they're definitely not also
consciously incompetent. So conscious
incompetence at that level.
And then they're doing that. And then when
they get started. And then when they get
started, when they open their trading
accounts, they apply themselves, they
implement with real money, what they have
learned, and they climb.
And they climb into the level of
competency. But what we're going to
introduce you to here now, and this is
important to look at at this stage in the
video series, is a breakdown of different
levels of competency based on experience.
So right at the bottom of competency
hierarchy, we have our retail traders
engaging in bad behaviors and operating in
a world of delusion, denial and lies, and
continually losing money.
We then have ITPM alumni. And typically
what we see whether alumni who have taken
our online programs, choose to trade
through ITPM infrastructure, or choose to
trade outside on their own, when they have
greater than 12 months experience, and a
certain amount of trades under their belt,
they begin to climb out of conscious
incompetence,
and into the level of conscious
competence, and into the level of
conscious competence, but without
question, within ITPM, because we have all
of the data, institute traders, who have
been trading over a 12 month period, and
have also got a certain amount of trades
under their belt.
So they've gained a level of experience as
a minimum of 12 months, and a certain
amount of trades under their belt. So
they've gained a level of experience as a
minimum of 12 months, and a certain amount
of trades over those 12 months, they are
sitting at the level of conscious
competence at a minimum.
So they've done online programs, they've
opened their trading accounts, they've
deposited money, they've traded over a 12
month period, and they've had some level
of minor success or decent success at a
minimum.
So at this stage, they know how to do it
right. But on some occasions, they may
need help still, and continue to get real
world practice, implementing the
knowledge.
Now guys like this in ITPM, who have been
trading greater than 12 months, they've
opened their trading accounts, they've
become an institute trader, and they've
got decent statistics, and they're
grinding out good results, positive
profit, so good P&L.
We refer to these guys in ITPM as
institute traders, so they've got the
knowledge, applying it pretty well.
But they may still be in some areas of
their trading, which is preventing them
from becoming at the level of unconscious
competence.
So the level of a professional trader,
where they can do it right by applying the
knowledge that we teach, and they make
really good returns, make good money,
without even thinking about it too much.
So their processes are close to perfect,
or perfect, they generate really high
quality ideas all the time.
And without thinking about it too much,
they have really solid preventative risk
management, and they know what to do in
pretty much all situations in terms of
reactive risk management.
So essentially, these guys, and we call
these guys Institute Traders Tier 1, these
guys are getting consistent profitability
by implementing ITPM processes, high
returns, and they're pretty much doing it
on autopilot.
So you'll notice with the visual, with the
competency hierarchy, Institute Traders
Tier 1 are sitting at the level of
unconscious competence, the same level as
professional traders, but the visual has
professional traders above them within the
unconsciously competent level of the
hierarchy.
But the Institute Traders Tier 1, the only
difference between those guys and
professional traders is really that
professional traders are registered as
professional traders and regulated by
their domestic regulator in whatever
geography they are in, and they are
registered to trade other people's money.
So shareholder money, if they're sitting
at an investment bank, or investor money,
if they're sitting at a hedge fund, and
the Institute Traders Tier 1 are not
registered or regulated, they're trading
their own money.
But other than that, there is essentially
no difference in the approach that they're
taking, and their ability to generate a
certain amount of return consistent out of
a sense of risk.
Both Institute Traders at Tier 1 and
professional traders are taking the same
approach, so the same input, and they're
getting the same output, and they engage
in all of the same behaviors.
Now, the reason why it's important to look
at this at this stage is because you have
to understand, right now, having done the
PTM video series, and also other online
programs at ITPM, like the IPLT video
series, and the Professional Options
Trading Masterclass.
You have to understand, at this stage,
where you sit in the hierarchy, and what
needs to be done to get you from that
level, so you continue climbing the
hierarchy.
And when you think about where we've come
from, right at the beginning of the video
series, up to this point, where we've gone
through the entire trade idea generation
process, and now we've arrived at
psychology and risk management, we can now
put all of this together to come up with
an entire educational development plan.
Because climbing the competency hierarchy
and getting to a professional trading
standard as a retail trader really
involves getting the right information and
internalizing it, knowing it really well
inside out.
So that's the theory, that's the
educational theory, then putting it into
practice with real money, so
implementation, and then not just
implementing it, but implementing it
successfully and consistently over a
period of time and a certain amount of
trades at a minimum, and gaining the
experience, the real world, real money
experience.
So you can feel very comfortable that
you've become highly competent at this
endeavor we call trading.
So right now, you would be classed, if you
are coming into ITPM, and you've just
taken the Professional Trading
Masterclass, you would be classed as ITPM
alumni under 12 months.
So you are sitting at the level of
conscious incompetence.
So if we go back one screen, and just look
at the definition here, so at the level of
conscious incompetence, it means that you
now know that you're doing it wrong, and
you have the right information to enable
learning and application.
So the good news is that you are no longer
unconscious.
unconsciously incompetent.
You've woken up, and you've become
conscious.
However, the key here in that definition
of conscious incompetence, the key word is
application.
You have to now implement to enable
yourself to get to the level of conscious
competence.
And if we look at the details here of what
makes an institute trader consciously
competent, it involves implementing
successfully everything that we've covered
in the PTM video series and the IPLT video
series up to this point.
And this provides you with your next
target.
Good.
So let's have a look at these.
Firstly, understanding risk versus
opportunity.
So fully understanding volatility and how
to calculate it.
Targeting a 50 to 100% return with
approximately a 20% and if possible above
20%, 20% plus annualized portfolio risk.
Knowing the difference between a trade
idea and an investment and having a
constant flow of high quality trade ideas.
Someone who is at the level of conscious
competence is also going to be highly
competent at timing the 20 to 60 day trade
entry and exit process.
And also very competent at optimal trade
structure and also very competent at
optimal trade structuring.
And this would also involve being
competent at trade structuring options
structures.
So yes, for you to be charging your way up
the competency hierarchy towards
professional level standard or
professional level status, it really is
unavoidable.
So at some point you're going to have to
become competent at trading options.
Now, somebody at the level of conscious
competence is also very good at building
long short 20 to 60 day portfolios and
doing it competently.
You know, the action of going longer stock
and shorter stock, it's all pretty
straightforward.
It's the push of a button on a keyboard.
But just engaging in that action and
building a portfolio by quickly buying six
stocks and shorting four stocks, you end
up with a long short portfolio as a
result.
But it doesn't mean you've done it
competently.
So execution in trading is also important
and how you actually go about building the
long short portfolio is very important
too.
In addition, what we found is that the
vast majority, if not all of institute
traders sitting at the level of conscious
competence have a very strong handle on
their trading psychology.
They don't fall in love with market
narratives and just as important, they
don't fall in love with their own internal
narratives and they don't fall in love
with their positions.
And that's because they do have a handle
on their trading psychology and engage
successfully in preventative risk
management and reactive risk management
practices.
So they are managing the risk of their 20
to 60 day long short portfolio very
competently and controlling their
psychology by a preventative risk
management and reactive risk management
practices.
And on top of that, they're also beginning
to understand or they're engaging in the
practice of treating their trading account
like a business.
They are hitting the trading statistics
that are necessary to run your account as
a business and therefore achieving self
sustainability and consistency in returns.
Now, the difference between consciously
competent traders and unconsciously
competent traders.
So the level of professionals really just
continues to come down to experience and
doing this on repeat over many trades over
a long period of time.
So it's not like unconsciously competent
or professional level standard traders are
doing anything different to consciously
competent traders.
It's just that they've got way more
experience and they've been doing it
longer so they can do everything that's on
the screen there.
So everything above without thinking too
much about it.
So they're in an autopilot situation.
They just know what has to be done and
they execute what has to be done without
even thinking about it.
And it just comes naturally.
So it's essential at this stage before you
go into the real world and start
implementing what you've learned with real
money that you understand what success
looks like in trading in terms of the
skill sets that you need in order to climb
the competency hierarchy.
And that's essentially what we have on the
screen right here.
The skill sets for conscious competence
and then what's required to go up into the
level of unconscious competence.
Now, to go from the level of conscious
competence to the level of unconscious
competence, i.e. the level of a
professional trading standard.
It, of course, comes down to experience.
But what is key is that you have to
understand that you have to treat trading
and your trading account as a business.
And the only way that can really be done
is by getting your psychology right and
essentially getting your head right.
So you can build your experience with real
money and real world implementation and
you know what to do in all situations.
And this is essentially called reactive
risk management or, in other words,
staying in motion on your positions.
Now, throughout your trading career,
especially in the beginning, you're going
to be coming across many different
situations when positions present
themselves as either winners, losers or
flat or nothing positions in terms of
outcome.
And assuming two people have the long
short portfolio management, 20 to 60 day
time horizon, systematic process in place,
and they know all the theory, the
difference between somebody who is at the
unconscious competence level and somebody
who is at the conscious competence level
is the ability to have strong reactive
risk management in terms of outcome.
That's the ability to have strong risk
management in terms of outcome.
So that's the ability to have strong risk
management to have strong risk management
in terms of outcome.
That's the ability to have strong risk
management in terms of outcome.
Being in motion on positions doesn't just
start off on the right path, but it just
gets better and better over time.
So the first situation we need to think
about is what we call in the industry,
when we have a position, a head scratcher.
So a position that you have, and you're
admittedly probably in the position for
all of the right reasons, but it's just
confusing.
You will often sit at your desk and stare
at positions in your trading account and
wonder why something isn't moving.
So you'll be asking yourself the question
many times in your career that you, for
example, did lots of work on a long idea.
It never goes up.
The stock has now gone against me.
It's down 10% from where you bought it.
And asking yourself the question, what on
earth should I do?
Well, we looked at preventative risk
management situations in earlier videos.
You can always have some sort of stop loss
in place, obviously.
But remember, you are running a long short
portfolio and there will be correlation in
your portfolio.
So there is no one size fits all rule book
that applies to all situations all the
time.
Every situation is dependent on its own
merits.
So remember, there is no rule book here.
But one thing is for certain, just using
the excuse like it's not working because
the technicals didn't play out is really
just a dumb excuse.
It's probably not going up because you've
actually missed something fundamental and
or catalyst driven.
So it's probably not going up because of a
lack of catalysts or you've missed
something fundamentally.
And in reality, there's multiple options
in how you treat this type of situation
versus just the binary make $3 or lose $1,
the three to one ratio on a trade.
The options in the way that you treat a
position like this are literally endless.
And what you have to remember as well is
that it's just one position in the context
of your entire portfolio.
The outcome of your portfolio is way more
important than the outcome of just one
position.
And this is why you have to eliminate all
emotion and stay objective all the time on
any position.
Now, something else that we have to
consider is something that we call a
stomach churner.
So when you've lost so much money that you
are actually sick to your stomach.
So this is what we call in trading and
portfolio management, the catastrophic
loss.
So you just log in one day into your
trading account and your account is just
down a massive amount of money.
Now, this can only happen for a few
reasons.
First of all, it could be a situation that
you just have far too much concentrated
risk in one situation.
So you're actually not diverse enough in
your portfolio.
So you didn't commit to actually building
a portfolio.
Secondly, it could be the case that
everything in your portfolio is just too
highly correlated and you've possibly
topped and tailed the portfolio.
So what does that mean in the context of a
long short portfolio?
Well, it could just mean that if the
market goes up 10% and all of your longs
and shorts went up between 10% and 20%
that you had hard stop losses on all of
your shorts and you got stopped out on all
of your shorts on the way up.
And now you're just naked long.
So you only have your long positions
remaining.
And then the market reverses and all of
your longs go down.
This means you've booked realized losses
on all of your shorts and realized losses
on all of your longs.
So essentially, what does that mean?
It means you've been hit with a double
whammy.
In that situation, everything was moving
in the same direction.
You probably had decent diversity in your
portfolio, but you had quite a bit of
correlation in your portfolio.
Volatility comes into the market.
All your stocks go up.
You get stopped out on all your shorts and
then all your stocks go down and you get
stopped out on all your longs.
And this actually may not be your fault.
Of course, putting hard stop losses on
every single position doesn't really work
in a long short portfolio.
You have to have a hybrid approach and
assess every situation by its own
individual merits.
And of course, if you did that and
volatility came into the market, you might
be a victim of the double whammy and it
might actually be your fault.
But what about the situation where, for
example, you walk in one day and all of
your shorts are up and all of your longs
are down?
Well, in that situation, it's just really
bad luck.
You've done everything right, but you just
got unlucky.
You've basically had what we call a three
or four standard deviation day.
Where on the very rare occurrence,
everything in your portfolio or the vast
majority of your portfolio just all goes
against you all at once.
So these two situations, the head
scratcher and the stomach churner are good
examples where if you don't get your head
right, you don't get your psychology
right.
As an amateur trader, a retail trader
starting out and going into the
implementation phase.
If you don't get that right, you can end
up struggling for a very long time, even
though you've got a high level
professional standard systematic process
in place.
Even worse, if you continue to have your
head in the wrong place, you have bad
psychology and bad preventative risk
management and the actions that you take
with your reactive risk management.
Even worse, you're just going to blow up.
Why?
Because it's absolutely inevitable that
you're going to have situations like this
all the time.
It's inevitable when you're trading with
real money in the markets and building
portfolios that you're going to always
have at any one time.
Winners, losers and positions that are
kind of flat and doing nothing.
So getting your head right, having the
right mindset and approach and knowing the
most probabilistic outcomes from your
actions is not only key to survival,
but also absolutely key to you climbing to
the highest level of the competency
hierarchy, unconscious competence and the
professional trader standard level.
So let's think about these things in terms
of getting our head right in terms of
outcomes when we have different situations
happening to positions in our portfolio at
any one time.
So there are literally only three outcomes
that can occur with a position.
There can't be any other outcome on a
position other than these three outcomes.
So straight away, this should give us some
sort of comfort in knowing that there's
absolutely no more outcomes than these
three situations.
It's not like trading is astrophysics or
particle physics.
It's not rocket science.
We've just got to understand it and know
how to deal with it.
And it's actually beautifully simplistic.
So on the slide here, you can see the
three outcomes.
And what we've done here is highlighted in
red what retail traders generally do and
highlighted in purple what professional
traders usually do.
So firstly, a big loss on a position, a
catastrophic loss.
What does a retail trader typically do
when they see a position go against them
wildly?
Well, generally speaking, most or all
retail traders will just be very scared.
Why?
Because they just don't know what to do.
And what retail traders typically do in
this situation is they just freeze like a
rabbit in the headlights.
So not even taking an action on the
position at all.
And therefore pulling from box A and even
worse, trying to add to the position and
average down with a losing position in the
hope that they can get back to break even
because they're so scared and they're so
panicked.
With professional traders, this just
doesn't happen.
Why?
Because we know there's a multitude of
actions that we can take to limit losses
and to control the damage and come out of
the situation doing not too bad out of it.
So we would usually have our preventative
risk management practices in place to make
sure that we are protected from a
catastrophic loss.
But also due to experience, having been
involved in some situations like that in
the past, we would have good reactive risk
management in place.
And even though there's a multitude of
things that we could do, we just wouldn't
panic and we'd assess all of the actions
that we could take with a clear mind.
We don't panic.
We don't get scared.
And we just trade based on probabilistic
outcomes.
So the catastrophic loss, the stomach
churner for professional traders, we know
there's absolutely no need to ever be
scared or panic because no one single
position can really kill us.
We construct our portfolios to absolutely
minimize the probability that a
catastrophic loss can occur.
And for us in the first place, because we
have preventative risk management
practices in place, we know that it's
extremely unlikely that we're going to
have a catastrophic loss in our portfolio
at all.
And that if we do have a three or four
standard deviation day where everything
just goes against us because it really is
unavoidable to take away all risk from
your portfolio from a catastrophic loss.
We understand that if it happens, it's
definitely down to really bad luck.
And even in that situation, we wouldn't
even be scared or panicked.
We would just do the right thing to make
sure we're trading tomorrow.
And that is just about capital
preservation.
Now, what about situations?
So our second outcome here where we're
just wrong on a position.
Well, even if it's not a catastrophic loss
at the individual stock level or the
overall portfolio level, retail traders,
if they're wrong on a position, will
generally be scared, confused and
panicked.
Whereas professional traders would just
never panic, even if they're wrong on a
position.
We would just engage in the right risk
management practices at the preventative
level, where if we were wrong on a
position, it definitely couldn't hurt us
too much.
And also we'd engage in reactive risk
management practices.
So taking actions on the position, given
new information in the market and the move
in price and just limit the damage that
the position can do to the outcome of our
portfolio.
But the key here is that we just don't
panic.
We look at things very clearly for what
they are.
We eliminate emotion.
We stay objective.
And we just do probabilistically the right
thing.
Now, what about our third outcome where
we're actually right on a position?
Well, retail traders, unfortunately,
engage in euphoria when they're right on a
position.
And even when retail traders generally are
experiencing euphoria because they're
right and they have a winner, something's
moved in their favor and they're making
good money on a position, they are still
essentially scared, confused and panicked.
And secondly, because the number that
they're looking at can be meaningful to
them, especially if they've had a lot of
previous losses.
So they get scared, confused and panicked
and then engage in box B behavior.
So taking profits on a winner too early.
With professional traders, even with a
winner, we're never going to be scared,
confused or panicked.
We don't, in that situation, engage in
emotion.
We never panic and we remain objective.
And similar to when we're wrong on a
position, we take a probabilistic approach
and we take the right actions for the
situation that we are in.
So to avoid all of these psychological
problems of being scared, confused and
panicked.
And then because of those psychological
problems causing us to do stupid things,
we put measures in place to stop us being
psychologically weak as in human.
Why? Because psychological weakness leads
to bad decisions, which leads to losses.
So immediately from the outset, before
going into the implementation phase, you
have to absolutely learn to become
agnostic.
You have to be able to learn how to
eliminate emotion from your thought
processes when trading and introduce total
objectivity to your psychology.
So whenever you're struggling with your
psychology and actually before you even go
on to implementation, you should engage in
this psychological meditation because it
will just help you put everything into
perspective.
It will get your head in the right place.
It will help you eliminate emotion and
stay objective so you engage in good
trading behaviors instead of bad trading
behaviors.
Therefore, in all situations, over time,
increasing your probability of making
money and decreasing the probability of
losing money over time.
So just think about the planet.
Think about Earth.
It's approximately 4,540,000,000 years
old.
And human ancestors date up to about 6
million years old.
Our species, the human species, is
approximately 200,000 years old.
And if we take a generation to be 25
years, that gives us 8,000 generations.
Now, modern civilization is only around
6,000 years old.
So this is about 240 generations.
And if you think about how long humans
have been around in the context of the
history of the Earth, the history of human
ancestors, and even when you think of your
own place in that history, and not just in
the history of the Earth and the history
of human ancestors, but also within the
context of human history itself with our
own species.
Your existence amounts to a tiny piece of
nothing.
So now think about the context of you
going into the financial markets to put on
a trade or take a trade off, as in to take
an action in the financial markets.
Think about that in this context.
It is a totally meaningless action.
So just think of the approach that many
amateur traders, many retail traders
engage in, and think about it in that
context, in the history of the Earth, the
history of human ancestors, and the
history of the human species.
And just think about how ridiculous those
actions are, or the approach that amateur
retail traders take.
For example, why would you ever think that
you're going to go into the financial
markets today and buy a stock at the
bottom, then sell it at some point in the
future at the top?
Why do amateur traders, and even amateur
investors, why do they act human?
Why do humans always think that they've
found something that's going to change the
world, and then they end up falling in
love with positions?
Does the financial market care that you,
as an individual in the entire history of
Earth, does the market care about what you
bought and the price that you bought it
at?
No, of course not.
The market doesn't care.
Additionally, if you think you're going to
go into the financial markets and pick the
bottom and pick the top, you're totally
delusional.
And if you fall in love with stories and
narratives, thinking that the stock
position that you have is in a company
that's got a product or service that's
going to change the world,
and you fall in love with positions, and
you just don't have the right mindset and
headspace to actually be an effective
trader.
We never expect to buy the bottom and sell
the top.
We never fall in love with narratives and
fall in love with positions, and we know
that the market doesn't care about what
price we bought something and what price
we sold it at.
Once you have a position in a stock, it's
just a ticker that you trade.
And you've bought the position in the
stock with a man-made invention.
Money, the stock itself, is a man-made
invention.
You're essentially just using fun credits
to make your life slightly better whilst
you have your time on Earth.
So just don't get emotional at all about
anything.
Just don't get emotional about positions
and fall in love with them.
Always stay objective.
You should just never, ever get emotional
about anything in trading financial
markets.
Why?
Because in the context of the history of
Earth, the history of human ancestors and
our own human species, it's all just
meaningless.
And once you understand that, you never,
ever have a reason to be emotional in any
situation in trading,
and you are going to remain calm and
objective in all situations.
So if you're ever worried, you're ever
scared, panicked, and confused, then you
should engage in this psychological
meditation
where you just, first of all, either lie
down on the floor or imagine yourself
lying down on the floor.
And then in the first step, raise above
yourself, out of your body, and just look
at yourself lying on the floor.
And then just zoom out.
So zoom out where you can be above
yourself, looking down at the neighborhood
that you're in.
Then zoom out again to look down at the
city that you're in.
Then zoom out again to look at which
country you're in.
Then continue to zoom out into space and
just imagine the Earth and how small your
country, your city, your neighborhood, and
you actually are.
Then zoom out to the solar system and
imagine where Earth is placed in the solar
system.
Then zoom out even further and imagine the
place of the solar system within our
galaxy.
Then after you've held that thought for a
small amount of time, zoom all the way
back.
So firstly, back to the solar system, back
to Earth, back to your country, back to
your city, back to your neighborhood, and
then back into your own body.
And I promise you, if you engage in this
psychological meditation, when you are
feeling scared, panicked, or confused in
any situation in financial markets,
when you open your eyes, log into your
trading account, and you look at the
situation that you're involved in, in
front of you, with your eyes, you will see
the situation in a totally different
light.
Why? Because you'll have a clear head.
You will know that being emotional, being
scared, confused, and panicked is totally
pointless because it's meaningless.
And that all you have to do is take the
right actions for that particular
situation that you are in, in that moment
in time in the history of the Earth.
And that being emotional about it just
will not serve you for the optimal
outcome.
So eliminating emotion and staying
objective in all situations in financial
markets is very, very important.
And you have to really learn how to
harness this skill set of eliminating
emotion and staying objective all the
time.
And if we're going to play this game
called trading the financial markets, we
just have to accept some absolute truths
of reality and stay objective around those
truths.
So one of these truths is when we go into
the market and we are potentially buying
or selling a stock, we need to just accept
that we're actually going to be down
instantly.
We're going to be losing money straight
away.
That's because when we enter the market,
we are buying on the offer and we are
selling or shorting on the bid side.
And then our P&L is marked on the other
side of the spread.
So if the spread in a stock is $25.72 to
$25.73, we are buying at $25.73 or we are
shorting at $25.72.
If we are buying or going long at $25.73,
our P&L is now marked at $25.72.
If we are shorting the stock at $25.72,
our P&L is now live and marked at $25.73.
So we just have to accept that it's a fact
of life.
As soon as we take a position, we should
expect to be down.
On top of that, we should always have
realistic expectations that we should
never think to ourselves that we are
actually ever going to pick the bottom
when going long or pick the top when we're
selling out of a long or going short.
We should just accept the reality and the
truth of financial markets that when we
enter a position, we are just going to be
down immediately and we should never
expect that we're going to pick the bottom
or pick the top.
Another truth that we acknowledge is that
our trading account is simply a business.
We expect losses to occur all the time as
well as profits.
But overall, we just want our gains to be
higher than our losses.
And this is how our business becomes
profitable.
We also admit to ourselves that our trade
ideas, even though we've put a ton of work
into them, they may not work in the
timeframe of 20 to 60 days.
And we just don't get emotional about it.
And we just admit that once we have a
position and the position is live, that
it's just a ticker on the screen and a
price on the screen that moves around.
And if it doesn't do what we want it to
do, we don't get angry about it.
We don't get emotional about it.
We don't cry or throw our computer
monitors across the room.
The stock that we have a position in is
just a stock trading over the 20 to 60 day
time period in the four and a half billion
year history of the earth.
It's meaningless and there's no reason
ever to be emotional about a position.
When we have to deal with a loser, when we
lose on a position, we just accept that
we're not going to get emotional about it.
And we're not going to go back into the
market to fight for our money back.
So we're engaging in what we call revenge
trading.
The stock doesn't care what price you
bought it at, what price you shorted it
at.
The stock doesn't care whether you've made
money or lost money.
From the two parties between a human and a
stock, it can only be the human that
cares.
And you're only going to care if you don't
treat your trading account like a business
and you get emotional about a stock
position.
You lose and you try to get revenge on the
stock.
The problem is the stock just doesn't
care.
In that situation, it's highly likely that
your emotion is going to lead to really
bad decisions and you're just going to
lose more money.
Another truth of financial markets that we
simply just have to deal with is that we
have to understand that we have to take
risk in order to get opportunity.
And we are actually on top of it.
So we understand the risk that we're
taking and the opportunity that this risk
presents.
Why?
Because we're intellectually honest with
ourselves about the risk and opportunity
within our time horizon.
And lastly, we have to be greedy.
We have to admit to ourselves that when
we're right, we have to choose to be
greedy.
But at the same time, we have to walk a
tightrope where we also are not afraid to
take profits.
After all, we are running a business.
So we have to realize profits.
We have to bank our profits.
So understanding these home truths about
financial markets is going to help you
move from conscious competence to
unconscious competence because you're
treating your trading account as a
business.
If you think about our three outcomes of a
trade and then look at the results, the
five results of those three outcomes, we
can look at them in the context of a
typical retail trader and also in the
context of a typical professional trader.
So this movement from conscious competence
to unconscious competence becomes easier
because even if we didn't tell you this
information, you would soon find out
yourself for real.
But to avoid bad situations or at least to
minimize them on your educational pathway
during the implementation phase, it really
doesn't take much effort for us to
highlight these situations to make the
pathway easier.
So when a retail trader experiences a
catastrophic loss, what happens?
What happens when a retail trader happens?
They just lose lots of money quickly.
It gets realized.
The business, the trading account takes a
massive hit, and there's no way back.
Additionally, retail traders are much more
susceptible to the catastrophic loss
because of all the behaviors they engage
in from the outset, as in not even having
a systematic process in place.
Next outcome, you were just wrong on a
position and this leads to two situations
for retail traders.
Either they have a stop loss in place and
they lose a predetermined amount of money,
so they're pulling from box B.
But in the vast majority of situations,
and this is why retail trader statistics
are so bad, or one of the main reasons is
they will pull from box A and lose a
non-predetermined amount that could lead
even further to a catastrophic loss.
Either way, generally speaking, when we
looked at this outcome, because retail
traders are generally uneducated, blind,
trading blind, and don't have a systematic
process in place, they will be scared,
confused, and panicked.
And generally speaking, they will lose a
non-predetermined amount because they
choose more risk and seek to fight the
market.
Next outcome, you are actually right on a
position and you're actually making money.
Well, retail traders, there's two outcomes
for any trader, but retail traders, we can
either have a predetermined amount that is
made, so there can be a hard target, or
there can be a non-predetermined amount
that could actually end up leading to
massive gains.
And this would be a situation where
there's a soft target in place with a
trailing stop that's being run.
Now, what would be the most typical
situation for a retail trader?
Well, it's probably going to be the box B
scenario where they're going to make a
predetermined amount.
Or even worse, which is extremely typical
of retail traders, is that the stops and
the targets are set at levels, given the
volatility of the asset in place, the stop
is set at a realistic level, given the
timeframe that they're trading and the
volatility of the asset, and the target is
set at an unrealistic level.
So when they have a winner in their
portfolio, the stock very rarely reaches
their target, losers always reach the
stop-loss very quickly, and winners very
often turn into losers and hit the
realistic stop-loss within the timeframe.
Plus, they're always in a situation where
the quality of their goals is so low that
a very high percentage of their positions
just end up being losers and they get
stopped out.
But even in the vast minority, where they
end up in a situation where they have a
winner and it hits their target, the
target is a hard target and they're taking
profits too quickly.
There is obviously also the situation
where, for example, they have a winner in
their portfolio, the target is very
unrealistic, it never actually gets there,
but they do roll the stop-loss and then
the winner turns into a small winner.
But this small winner is nowhere near
enough to offset all of the losers
combined.
So with these three outcomes and the five
results, retail traders, when they have
these three outcomes, engage in the
incorrect behaviors which lead, over time,
over many trades, to just bad results.
Now, with professional traders, the five
results for professional traders, things
are just different.
Why?
Because we admit to ourselves all of the
truths of financial markets and trading,
we put our preventative risk management
measures in place, we have solid reactive
risk management practices, and we never
get emotional and we always stay
objective.
And we seek to take the right action at
the right time in the situation that we
find ourselves in.
So the first outcome, the catastrophic
loss, what's the result here for
professional traders and why does it
differ to retail traders?
Well, firstly, it happens a lot less.
Why?
Because we're eliminating the probability
of this happening as much as possible
through diversification.
So only a three or four standard deviation
event can actually make this happen, which
means it's just down to extremely bad
luck.
Additionally, if it does happen because
we've been involved in some of these
situations throughout our careers, we
don't panic, we don't get emotional, we
stay objective, and we just do what we
have to do.
The next outcome where we're actually
wrong on a position, rather than being
scared, confused, and panicked, and
getting emotional about it, we stay
objective and we take the approach of
handling the situation with as much care
as possible.
And our outcomes are different because of
preventative risk management and because
of reactive risk management.
But most importantly, what sets
professional traders apart at the
unconsciously competent level to traders
operating at conscious competence is how
we actually react to these situations.
So reactive risk management.
So by handling with care, this outcome
where we're just wrong on a position, we
aim for two results.
Instead of losing a predetermined amount
or a non-predetermined amount that ends up
leading to a catastrophic loss, we take
actions to prevent that and we get two
results typically.
We either book a small loss so we're
losing a little bit of money and this is
achieved, generally speaking, by just
unwinding the position sensibly and by
making some money back through our
actions.
Secondly, if we've done this really well
and we've traded well out of the position,
we can actually get out for flat or even
make a small amount of money from a bad
situation.
So when we are wrong on a position, we
generally don't have a predetermined
amount that we lose and we certainly don't
have a non-predetermined amount that we
lose that can turn into a catastrophic
loss.
We've just been doing it for so long and
have good experience, we know what to do.
We know and recognize when we're wrong on
a position and we get busy and we take
action.
Next up, the outcome of when we're
actually right on a position, we have a
winner in our portfolio, we're up, we're
making money and we're feeling vindicated
and confident.
With this outcome, we are generally aiming
and we typically get two results.
Firstly, because we know we're running a
business and realized P&L is important, we
can book a decent amount of profit along
the way, but we maintain a small position
so we can make even more.
Or secondly, we can book a decent amount
of profit along the way and we can
actually go bigger in the position at a
combination of more advantageous prices
and or at a better time.
And then with the position that we have,
the new position, we would roll our stop
loss and that stop loss would protect all
or very close to all of the profit that
we've realized to that point.
So the point here about the outcomes and
the results is that they are very
different between professional traders and
retail traders typically.
So for the catastrophic loss, it's very,
very unlikely that it's going to happen to
professional traders because of all of the
measures we put in place.
And even if it did happen, we can handle
it with retail traders.
Typically, it's going to happen a hell of
a lot more.
And when it does, they just can't handle
it.
When professional traders are wrong on a
position, so we have a bad outcome.
So we're just wrong.
We either lose a little bit of money or
get out for flat or even make a small
amount of money from the bad situation.
With retail traders, they're either losing
typically a predetermined amount because
of a stop loss or a non predetermined
amount that can lead to a catastrophic
loss.
When it comes to being right, when we have
a winner, professional traders from this
outcome tend to get two results.
We either book a decent amount of profit
and we continue to make more money on the
position by maintaining a smaller size
position or we book a massive profit.
Because after booking a decent amount of
profit along the way, we go back into the
position and we go much bigger.
With retail traders, they're either
booking a predetermined profit and usually
down to a combination of lots of bad ideas
and very few good trade ideas and setting
unrealistic targets.
For retail traders, those hard targets are
actually very rarely met.
And even if they are or their rolled stop
loss gets triggered, the winners, the
dollar amount on the winners doesn't cover
the dollar amount of all of the losers
combined.
So you can really understand here the
difference of the outcomes and the results
for professional traders relative to
retail traders because of preventative
risk management and most importantly,
reactive risk management.
Because of the professional traders
ability to risk manage reactively, the
outcomes of the catastrophic loss simply
being wrong on a position or being right
on a position lead to very different
results.
And this is why it's so important to make
sure that you have risk management
practices in place in order to be sitting
in the level of conscious competence and
also to build up a large amount of
experience of trading many situations over
a long period of time to build up a more
sophisticated risk management approach in
practice.
So you can get into the level of
unconscious competence.
So the level of the professional trading
standard because the actions that
professional traders engage in on a
weekly, monthly basis are generally more
sophisticated than the binary outcome of
simply losing one and making three.
So hard stop losses and hard targets.
And it's really only possible to engage in
these actions on autopilot unconsciously
once you've built up a lot of experience.
Another option, of course, to get better
at these situations at these actions quite
quickly is to simply have a professional
trader sitting with you or sitting on your
shoulder and showing you how to do it.
And unfortunately, this is only something
that can be done in practice because
everything is situational depending on the
situation that you're in at the time in a
particular stock.
And there is an infinite amount of actions
that can be taken.
So it just simply can't be taught in a
video series.
And there is no such thing as a rule book
which tells you what to do in all
situations all the time in every stock
forever.
So the way ITPM solves this issue is
through mentoring programs.
Obviously, you would learn a hell of a lot
more than justice on a mentoring program,
but reactive risk management is covered.
So if you do struggle with this or you
want to obtain this skill set as quickly
as possible, then you should absolutely
consider a mentoring program with one of
the ITPM senior trading mentors.
But if you are going to join the Institute
as an Institute trader or you're going to
go off alone by yourself outside ITPM,
that's okay.
You're going to build up the experience
over a number of trades over a period of
time, 12 to 18 months, 100 to 150 trades.
And hopefully the penny is going to drop
at some point and things will fall into
place where most of the time you take the
right actions at the right times and you
learn to get the results of professional
traders from those three outcomes.
Just make sure that you go over all of the
trading psychology videos and the
preventative risk management practices and
just make sure that you've got your head
and psychology in the right place and your
PRM, your preventative risk management in
place and your reactive risk management
actions will come over time with
experience.
So in terms of preventative risk
management, just running through a quick
example, if you have a 10 position
portfolio, let's say with five longs and
five shorts that are equally weighted,
what happens if one position goes against
you by a large amount?
Let's say 50%.
Well, that in your portfolio is going to
be a negative 5% portfolio performance.
If it goes against you 100%, then it's
going to be a negative 10% portfolio
performance.
And this is totally recoverable.
So you're just making sure there that
you're diverse enough.
Where in the situation one position goes
wildly against you, you are still in a
totally recoverable scenario.
So diversification goes a very long way to
eliminating the catastrophic loss.
You've also got to make sure that you have
low correlation and or even some negative
correlation across ideas, but overall a
low positive correlation for your
portfolio.
So it's going to require a three or four
standard deviation event that is going to
hurt you, which is going to be highly
improbable, highly unlikely.
What this does is it eliminates the
chances, eliminates the probability that
you're going to panic when there's market
moves that are quite sizable.
So it's going to stop you topping and
tailing the portfolio.
You just won't need to panic ever.
So this all in combination in terms of
PRM, it removes the possibility of the
catastrophic loss.
And it also minimizes the psychological
downside that leads to bad decisions and
continual losses.
And by the way, these preventative risk
management practices, when you put them in
place, it can totally be achieved without
the need to give up the upside.
As you've seen in previous videos in the
PTM video series, mostly covered by Chris,
you can still take calculated risk in your
portfolio by choosing the level of risk
that you want within the framework.
And you can still post great risk adjusted
returns.
Now, when it comes to reactive risk
management, this is something, if you
choose to go alone, that you're going to
just have to pick up yourself over time
with experience.
And as we've seen, the differences between
pro traders and retail traders in this
respect are numerous.
And the most startling difference is
always how losers and winners are treated
or traded by professional traders relative
to retail traders.
Obviously, professional traders have got a
lot more experience in how to contain
losses and maximize winners through trial
and error over many years of real trading
with real money in real situations over
and over again on repeat.
And whether it's how we treat losers or
how we treat winners, what we call this in
the industry is staying in motion.
And what we're doing here is that we're
always playing the probabilities, not the
possibilities.
There's a very big difference in financial
markets and outcomes in financial markets
with portfolios and positions between what
is possible and what is actually probable.
And when we pro traders are actually
taking actions on our positions, we are
taking actions based on what is probable,
not what is remotely possible.
And yes, we don't obviously get everything
right all the time with our actions.
But if we're taking a probabilistic
approach over many situations over a long
period of time with our three outcomes,
we're going to get better results.
So if you are going off by yourself,
whether that's outside ITPM or becoming an
institute trader, you've got to understand
to take the approach, the probabilistic
approach, not trading remote
possibilities.
And the difference in psychology is really
twofold.
Firstly, with fundamentals, because we as
pro traders, we do our fundamental
homework.
We know why a stock is moving.
So we know it's because of the
fundamentals and it's not down to
something random like an excuse like the
technicals didn't play out.
So in a winning situation, we are much
more confident to run the position or in a
losing situation, we're much more
confident in staying in motion if
necessary.
Secondly, we just never have a situation
where we're sick to our stomach, where we
have stomach churners and we're just never
married to positions.
Why? Because we know that going into every
position, it doesn't matter what it is,
that we're going to treat all positions in
the same way.
And we just don't get emotional or get
tied to narratives or stories when we're
either up in on a winner or down on a
loser.
So just having the right psychology in
place really helps with your reactive risk
management, even if you're just starting
out and going it alone.
So just make sure that your psychology,
your head is in the right place when you
start trading, when you start implementing
what you've learned in the PTM video
series.
And you're taking the approach of trading
your account as if it's a real business.
You have to make sure that when you go
into this, that you're on the front foot
and that you're willing to stay in motion
on your positions because you are running
a business now.
Your trading account is a business.
You can't be in a situation where you just
stare at positions and do nothing.
You will have to take action on your
positions.
So essentially, you will have to
continually stay in motion.
This is something that is unavoidable in
financial markets and trading financial
markets if you want to get to the
professional level standard of trading.
So how do we actually go about staying in
motion?
Well, assuming that you have good
diversification in your portfolio, good
ideas.
You've got controllable position sizes and
you're executing at decent prices.
How do we actually go about actively
trading a long short portfolio?
Well, again, there's no hard and fast
rules here, but there's just common sense
guidelines and best practices or
parameters that you're probably going to
be adhering to.
So we are operating in the 20 to 60 day
time horizon.
And it really depends on many variables,
but the outcome of a position starts to
become known generally in the first month
when we have the position on.
So around 20 days.
Now, of course, it also depends on the
specific situation.
So it depends on the catalysts in that
situation.
But when things start to play out, the
position is either going to be a clear
loser or a clear winner or it's going to
be somewhere in between.
So what we call a nothing position.
And if you're going to stay in motion
effectively and run your account as a
business, you have to understand that in
our trading statistics, we will always
have an unrealized P&L and a realized P&L.
And in the next section of the PTM video
series, Chris Quill is going to go through
a lot of these trader statistics with you.
But for now, just understand the
difference between unrealized P&L and
realized P&L.
Your unrealized P&L is all of your live
positions in your trading accounts that
are what we call marked to market.
So your P&L is marked at the last price of
each stock that you have a position in.
The point is, is your unrealized P&L is
not real because you still have the
positions on and you haven't taken them
off yet.
When you take them off, they become
realized.
So when you take a position off, your P&L
is crystallized.
So with losers beyond, say, around 40
days, we're probably starting to wonder if
our margin in our trading account is
better spent somewhere else.
So in all probability, we're probably
going to start to take our medicine and
we're going to book some losses or an
overall loss on the position.
And these losses are going to be realized
in our trading account.
So realized losses in our business.
Now, how do we counter that so our
business is being run effectively?
Well, with winners, we are banking profits
along the way into the realized column and
we are keeping the cash register ringing
and we're seeking to keep that realized
column, the dollars in the realized column
going higher and higher all the time,
regardless of the fact that we're also
booking some losses.
So even though we're booking some losses
at the same time, we are seeking to keep
the realized column going up.
And after we've taken profits along the
way, banking those profits along the way
with winners to offset losses, we're
generally seeking to potentially go back
into winners or just move on to the next
trade.
Now, it's important to remember that this
is not an everyday thing.
Typically, what will happen is that your
P&L bookings into the realized column are
going to come in clusters.
And this tends to happen when there's some
volatility around your stocks in your
portfolio are moving around and you'll do
several trades all at once.
This is not an everyday thing.
Now, when you're staying in motion and
you're running your trading business, so
the realized column keeps going higher and
you're banking profits along the way out
of winners to offset losers.
And overall, on a net basis, you're
booking a profit overall because of those
actions.
If the only reason that you've come out of
a winner is to make sure that the realized
dollars are going higher because you're
booking a loss somewhere else.
Of course, it's highly likely that you're
going to go back in at some point to the
winner after making sure that nothing has
changed fundamentally or the fundamentals
have gone in your favor further.
The action of banking profits along the
way to offset losers and more is an action
in the industry that we call trading the
P&L and you want to be very careful not to
trade your P&L too often.
Why? Because again, the stock doesn't care
what price you bought and sold the stock
at.
The stock is just going to do what it
wants to do.
And in a situation where the stock
continuously goes in the direction that
you believe it's going to go in and it's
presented itself as a winning position,
it's more than likely going to continue on
that trend.
So you actually have to trade the stock,
but at the same time, not be reckless that
you're never trading the P&L and not
admitting that you are running a business.
So we are constantly walking a tightrope
between what we call trading the stock and
also trading the account as a business.
And it's a fine balancing act to achieve
in many situations over a long period of
time.
It takes a while to get used to, but
you'll just get it over time with
experience.
So in this quite typical situation where
you do have a winner in your portfolio and
you're banking profits along the way to
offset the dollar losses from a loser and
making sure that overall you are booking a
profit in the realized column, it is quite
likely that you're going to go back in to
the winner.
So you're looking after your business
first and foremost, but then you're also
trading the stock and not missing the
opportunity to make even more money on the
winner.
And of course, you're not in a rush.
You don't have to go back in immediately.
Just be opportunistic.
Now, with nothing positions, those
positions where after a period of time,
they haven't presented themselves as a
clear winner or a clear loser.
They're just hovering around flat.
We can actually be active here as well in
order to protect our downside.
But we do most of the time keep the upside
open just in case.
So in all situations, but in particular on
these nothing positions, try to avoid
trading on noise like a piece of news flow
that really doesn't mean anything for the
stock.
Just take this action solely for risk
management purposes.
If you're taking the action of just
trimming and booking small losses from
what we call a nothing position, it's
totally okay.
You're going to have other positions in
your portfolio that are winners that are
going to offset these small losses.
So don't worry about it.
But at the same time, you don't have to be
extreme in these situations.
You always have the choice of just having
a smaller position in nothing positions.
Never close off all of the upside, the
dollar upside potential of a nothing
position.
Just get to a controllable size and be a
little bit more patient.
Now, when it comes to running your trading
account as a business and going from the
level of conscious competence up to the
professional level of unconscious
competence, there are some absolute do not
actions.
So these are the closest things in terms
of reactive risk management.
These are the closest actions you will
ever get to a rule book.
When it comes to losses and you're
experiencing losses, understand that
you're running a business and you have an
unrealized P&L and a realized P&L.
Just never take the action of only booking
just losses.
Always come out of what we call a booking
flurry, having made realized gains
overall.
And you have to do this even if it means
taking off a large percentage of your
entire trading account.
Because you're running a business, you
have to keep realized gains charging
upwards.
You can always go back into winners.
So just make sure you do not book only big
losses.
Once it's realized P&L, or in this
situation, a very big realized L, it can
never be taken back because it's now
realized.
You have to seek to offset it with
winners.
And if you're trading a spread trade,
don't only book the losing side of a
spread and run the winning side.
Why?
Because you're making the loss realized
and the winner, the profit is not profit.
It's unrealized.
And you open yourself up to the situation
where you're booking a loss on the losing
side of a spread.
You then run the winning side of a spread.
And then the winning side of the spread
turns into a losing position, which means
you lose money on both sides of a spread.
After you've been in the actual situation
where overall you are up on the spread.
A much better action would be to book both
sides of the spread where you take the
loss and you take the gain.
And overall, on a net basis, you are up.
So your business, which is the realized
P&L, is actually up.
And then you go back into the winning side
of the spread.
So, of course, we try as much as possible
to stick to the principle of trading the
stock and not the P&L.
However, we have to just admit to
ourselves that our trading account is a
business and we need that realized P&L
column always going up on a net basis.
So we don't want to be reckless.
If you just find yourself in a situation
where you're booking big losses over and
over into your realized column.
And you're hoping that your unrealized
winners will pay even more in the future.
You're engaging in bad business practices
for your trading account.
This is a pathway, a road that just leads
to hell.
As a trader portfolio manager, you need to
protect your realized P&L column with your
life.
Now, one of the biggest mistakes that we
see at ITPM is newbie traders, retail
traders, even having taken our programs,
not staying in motion at all.
And or people are choosing to stay in
motion, but they're just doing it really
badly.
So reactive risk management and staying in
motion.
It's really a skill set in itself that you
can only learn by doing it with real
dollars over many trades over a decent
period of time.
So the realities of this business and
running a trading account is that you not
only need to turn yourself into a trade
idea generation monster.
You also need to turn yourself into a
banking beast.
And when you combine the two being a trade
idea generation monster and being a really
effective risk manager, especially with
reactive risk management and becoming a
banking beast.
This in your business, your trading
account leads to your realized P&L always
going up.
And it means the cash register of your
business is ringing on a regular basis.
Every time you're moving P&L from
unrealized to realized, you should just
always remember the ring of a cash
register.
Are you taking the right action and being
up in the realized column on a net basis?
Are you putting dollars into the register
or are you taking dollars out of the
register?
You need to always keep the register
ringing and you have to make solid and
sensible decisions and play the
probabilities, not the possibilities.
And just to hammer this point home, we
have here the visual of an actual cash
register in a business.
And what's the cash register actually
asking you to do?
The cash register is asking you to please
put money inside me and please don't take
it away.
You are running a business here, guys.
OK, your trading account is a business and
the actions that you take in your reactive
risk management is really going to
determine whether you're putting money
consistently into that register.
Or you're consistently taking money out.
Your realized column is your business.
It's your cash register.
Protect your realized column with your
life and keep it charging upwards.
So, of course, reactive risk management,
staying in motion.
It can't be taught in a video series.
It has to be done with real experience,
with real money and real positions.
However, in the PTM video series here,
what I've done in this video is try to set
you off on the right path in the context
of psychology.
In terms of teaching reactive risk
management and doing this properly in
practice, it can really only be taught to
the professional level on a trading desk
or in a mentoring program with real money
through demonstration.
We've done hundreds of mentoring programs
down the years at ITPM.
And anyone who has done a mentoring
program at ITPM will actually know this.
So, at this stage, if you haven't done a
mentoring program or you don't plan to,
then this, the reactive risk management
and staying in motion is a skill set that
you're going to have to learn for yourself
over a longer period of time.
On a mentoring program at ITPM, you'll be
shown a lot of things, including reactive
risk management, and you will become
consciously competent at everything,
including reactive risk management within
three months.
But as with anything in trading, the real
test comes when you go off by yourself.
And the only way you're going to be
unconsciously competent as a trader is if
you can implement all of this by yourself
without someone looking over your shoulder
and supervising you.
If you make the decision to go alone
outside ITPM or inside ITPM, that's
totally fine.
But even as an institute trader, you will
need 12 months and at least 100 to 150
trades behind you.
Now, at this stage, moving from theory
into implementation, it can be quite
daunting, but you just shouldn't be
scared.
You've learned an absolutely huge amount
of very valuable information.
And you're getting to the stage now where
you are about to go into implementation
stage, and you just shouldn't be worried
because you've been taught extremely well
to a very high level.
And especially if you pass the exam at the
end of the PTM video series, it means
you've absorbed all the information, you
understand it, and you're in a very, very
strong position to go forward into
implementation.
So you should feel confident.
But it is hard work.
This is where the hard work actually
begins.
And look, no one ever said this was going
to be easy.
Do you recall the four principles of the
institute?
Well, I'm not going to remind you again
here for the sake of repetition.
Please go and remind yourself again.
Financial markets and trading is a tough
environment and occupation.
To become consistently profitable, you
really do have to have the right
information and then apply yourself.
And you do have to work pretty smart to
become consistently good.
So don't shoot the messenger.
This is just how financial markets and
trading them successfully over a long
period of time actually works.
If you want to take shortcuts, that's
totally fine by us.
You will just end up going back to the
unconsciously incompetent level and you'll
just keep going around in circles and
you'll just be back again at some point in
the future.
We're getting close to the time now where
you're about to move into implementation
and it's just time to make a choice.
You either continue on the road to
becoming successful at trading to a
professional level standard and therefore
keeping the educational momentum going.
Or you decide to stagnate and not keep the
momentum going and stay where you are at
conscious incompetence.
Or you reverse course and you end up being
unconsciously incompetent again.
If your choice is to keep the momentum
going, then yes, it's going to take some
application and you're going to have to
implement based on the four principles of
ITPM.
And just get your head down and grind out
the results.
And speaking of results coming up in the
next section of the PTM video series.
Chris Quill is going to show you through
trader statistics and metrics the results
that you should be aiming for and also how
to measure your performance as a trader.
So you are always on top of your business,
your business performance, your business
statistics.
But first, we've come to the end now of
our section in the PTM video series of
trading psychology and risk management.
So let's summarize here.
So when it comes to psychology, we looked
at human psychology and its flaws when
trading financial markets.
We also looked at some basic preventative
risk management practices.
And we did this to understand why they
actually exist.
And we looked into them in the context of
the 20 to 60 day long short portfolio
mandate.
What we've also looked at here actually
are the consequences of ego and thinking
that you know better than the market or
you know something that the market
doesn't.
So we looked at taking on the market and
the result of that.
We looked at the catastrophic loss.
We also looked at the differences between
retail traders and pros when it comes to
psychology and risk management practices.
And probably the biggest difference
between retail traders and pro traders
when it comes to risk management is ego.
Professional traders just don't pretend.
We recognize our ego.
We acknowledge it and we embrace it.
And we put measures in place to stop
ourselves being egotistical when trading.
What's ironic is that retail traders in
reality, on the other hand, pretend to be
humble.
And therefore they don't actually
acknowledge their ego and they don't have
any measures in place to prevent their ego
from destroying them.
So what's funny is that out there in the
world is a perception that professional
traders are very arrogant and have very
big egos.
But this is just a perception because in
reality, you simply can't be successful at
trading and be consistently profitable
over time if you actually have a big ego
and you're arrogant.
And in reality, it's not professional
traders who get those results over time
who are the ones with the big egos and who
are arrogant.
Because to get the results, you have to
acknowledge your ego and put measures in
place to prevent your ego from destroying
you.
It's just a human condition and
professional traders understand that they
have to make sure they control it.
The irony is that retail traders pretend
or perceive themselves to be humble.
Yet in reality, they have the biggest
egos.
They don't acknowledge their egos and they
don't put measures in place to control it.
And their egos and their human psychology
end up destroying them.
So guys, as you're moving forward into the
implementation phase, just understand
human nature, understand human psychology
and understand the difference between that
and trading psychology and why we have
risk management practices in place.
And make sure you put measures in place to
control your human psychology and your
ego.
If you have any ambition to climb the
competency hierarchy when you go into the
implementation phase and you're trading
with real money, this is unavoidable.
You are going to have to learn how to do
this in practice.
But as mentioned multiple times in this
section of the video series, the more you
practice and the more experience you get,
the better you're going to get at risk
management and understanding the trading
psychology versus human psychology.
So guys, we're going to move into the next
section of the PTM video series now.
And Chris Quill is going to be showing you
how to run your trading account as a
business.
So how you measure your effectiveness,
your performance as a trader.
So what Chris is going to be showing you
are the measures by which you yourself and
outsiders judge your business so you
actually treat your trading account as a
business.
So how you measure your trading account as
a business.
Thank you.